hi I'm coffee break and welcome to fan
mail Friday I can't be a Friday anyone
maybe this makes up for all the fake
doers that I missed but I just want to
cover somebody's uh fan mail they sent
me and just answer a question that I got
that was sincere and so I want to answer
it sincerely this was from actually I
had an email from a fake guru believe it
or not here let me get this pull this up
this person's email was titled serious
question of regarding sales training
channel so they've been in sales for 19
years I'll just summarize this I'm not
going to include their name because I
think they sent me this in good faith
but they said look I like your stuff you
know you have some good critiques but
I'm trying to start a channel that's
gonna run a course and I want to know
what you think of fair prices what I
think is fair prices and they said you
know what type of course would be worth
two thousand three thousand dollars I
said look I could do interviews expert
interviews that what would be worth two
to three thousand dollars of people's
money and this is where I just have to
get brutally honest with you guys
nothing absolutely nothing is worth two
to three thousand dollars that is a
course just due to the democratization
of information and due to everything
being online and in book format for so
much less there's no justifiable reason
to run a course an information course
with a primary product as information
for more than it costs for to buy a book
that's just me being honest actually why
that's like even though I love talking
about the e fake gurus and all that
stuff and the goofy things they do to
try to get people kind of suckered in I
have a problem with anyone who sells a
two to three thousand dollar information
course unless that information is
available nowhere else I think it's
extremely predatory and it preys on
desperate people the fact is is that the
demographics of these fake gurus is not
you know thirty five year old with a
bunch of disposable income that want to
better themselves it's eighteen year
olds it's people without this money so
we have to think about that
when we think about these things we also
have to think about the true it's sort
of intrinsic value of the information of
course it is all about how you package
it but when you're targeting and selling
dreams dreams of financial freedom to
eighteen year olds who don't know better
that's when I have a problem and you
just don't get around that selling
courses at least individuals there
really just is no excuse to be charging
two thousand dollars three thousand
dollars $500 anything more than a book
because truthfully we already have
experts in sales mindset all everything
you could ever make a course about and
they write books about it in far more
detail that a fake guru course ever gets
and they charge like ten bucks for it so
in the spirit of you know kind of sort
of my personal philosophy I realized
that sometimes just telling people that
oh such-and-such isn't a good thing to
do such as so-and-so you probably don't
want to buy its course or her course I
realized you know people rightfully say
to me if they go okay Steven well I
still need a way to get out of the
situation I'm in I'm trying to better
myself Oh wha how do I do that and and
this bit on this channel I don't give
you guys a lot of resources for that
so tentatively I'll probably announce
the full thing later but tentatively I'm
starting my coffee Zilla bake guru
course which all it is is it is a it is
a set of books that I believe in or have
been recommended by people that I trust
and they are basically no more than
twenty dollars a pop they're averaging
about ten bucks twelve bucks on Amazon
and they're in all sorts of different
genres that you could be interested in
mindset all these different kind of
things and then over and then I total
the cost of taking the full coffee Zilla
fake guru course I think is up to like
three hundred dollars but if you read
every one of those books you'd be
it'd be the equivalent of taking like 20
50 root courses I mean the amount of
information in these books for the cost
is so much more efficient than going and
taking some insane fake guru course so
the only difference besides much cheaper
price is that these books don't promise
to change transform your life and make
you you know some big success so so
fundamentally I just philosophically
disagree with anybody charging two
thousand dollars to to what is what are
always gonna end up being kids you know
the people taking these courses it's not
successful people my definition it is
it's eighteen-year-old men usually
they're the ones who usually get
suckered
18 to 22 year olds looking for a way out
who may may have a high school diploma
or something like this
and it's like they're they're looking
for better prospects and then they end
up getting sort of scammed because
they're told that it's something it's
not and you could get so much more value
by just reading a couple bucks the cost
get twenty bucks ten bucks and that's
not even to say like if you actually
tried to save money I mean that these
are all Amazon links that I'm posting go
to a library you can get most of these
books free just a library card get your
stupid library card out or go and look
book PDF you know ever done that that's
a lot of books are just available free
online so anyway that's available and if
you think I left anything out in my book
recommendation list for the copies of
FAQ of course you can definitely
recommend I also put a Google Form to
recommend so anyway that's all that's
the fan mail answer of the day is there
such a thing as a two thousand dollar
course that's worth it no
[Music]
[Music]
Sakura
[Music]